my fans and me we're in love the arena  is our bedroom and the stage the stage  is where we [ __ ] corner for real is  actually be saving the record industry  you tell me you didn't see him and say  yo he's the star this guy right here  he's gonna make it big  Connor currently is 32 people on his  personal payroll Connor surrounds  himself with people who are agreeable  all my would work it's kind of my  passion this was a mask still me justin  bieber's goddess believers and I've got  my confidants best fans in the biz it's  kind of a perfect job for me but my  favorite free time theme is flatlining  oh wow  I [ __ ] my pants at this time I'd love to  get Connor to the point where he's just  kind of everywhere like oxygen or  gravity or clinical depression he's just  everywhere surprise [ __ ] in a  way gracious is my weakness people say  pretentious you know it takes a village  to make me look dough that's why I'm  here  we need to be put the check